tenemos aquí a la función hdx que es
igual a 5 por equis elevada a la
potencia un cuarto más 7 y nos
preguntamos cuánto vale h prima en 6 o
sea cuánto vale la derivada de la
función h
si la evaluamos cuando x es igual a 16 y
como siempre ponle pausa este vídeo e
intentar resolverlo por tu cuenta
bueno vamos a sacar esta derivada vamos
a sacar primero la derivada del lado
izquierdo y esa es simplemente h prima
de x y luego para sacar la derivada del
lado derecho podemos simplemente primero
sacar la derivada de este término y
después sumarle la derivada de 7 con
respecto a x entonces vamos a empezar
con la derivada de este término podemos
simplemente utilizar la regla de las
potencias pero esto aquí podría decirme
oye espérame un momento aquí la potencia
es una fracción se puede utilizar la
regla de las potencias cuando la
potencia es una fracción iii
y si se puede la regla de las potencias
es muy poderosa así es que vamos a tomar
esta potencia la vamos a multiplicar por
el coeficiente y entonces tenemos 5 por
un cuarto un cuarto y luego
multiplicamos por x elevada a la
potencia un cuarto menos uno pero luego
tenemos por aquí más siete y cuál es la
derivada de siete con respecto a x el 7
no cambia cuando cambia x el 7 es una
constante y hemos visto que las
derivadas de las constantes son 0 y
ahora ya nada más nos falta simplificar
esta expresión
tenemos que h prima de x es igual
cinco cuartos por equis elevada a la un
cuarto menos uno pero cuánto es un
cuarto menos uno bueno pues esto son
menos tres cuartos porque porque tenemos
un cuarto menos cuatro cuartos y esos
son menos tres cuartos y luego tenemos
más cero pero eso no lo tenemos que
escribir y listo esta es la derivada de
la función h ahora nosotros lo que
queremos es la derivada de h pero
evaluada en 16 entonces vamos a
evaluarla en 16 h prima de 16 es igual
tenemos cinco cuartos por 16 elevado a
la menos tres cuartos
es igual a cinco cuartos
1 entre 16 elevado a la tres cuartos y
eso también es igual a cinco cuartos por
uno entre 16 elevado a la un cuarto y
eso elevado a la tercera potencia pero
esto a cuánto es igual
bueno pues 16 elevado a la un cuarto es
2 y 2 elevado a la 3 es 8
así es que tenemos cinco cuartos por un
octavo y todo eso es igual a 5 entre 4
por 8 32 y esta es la respuesta h prima
en 16 son 5 32avos